[Musique]
le festival de cannes ce n'est pas que
du cinéma l'événement est aussi réputé
pour ses nuits l'une d'elles a été
animée une nouvelle fois par des
yvelinois macadam crocodile s'est
produit vendredi dernier dans l'une des
soirées les plus sélects de la croisette
nous les avions a suivi il y a un an
depuis le groupe a enregistré son
premier album en live c'est la réunion
de deux amis vincent et xavier ont
fréquenté le même lycée dans leur
jeunesse à la celle saint cloud après
des carrières respectives dans la
musique les yvelinois se retrouvent et
font de macadam crocodiles le duo était
de retour à cannes pour se produire dans
l'une les soirées du 72e festival comme
il ya un an c'était sur la terrasse du
fife six hôtels c'est toujours sympa de
venir parce que on croise plein de gens
qu'on ne voit pas forcément pendant
qu'on est en tournée il ya plein d'amis
musiciens la comen et d'intelligent ya
plein de gens qu'on croise sur la route
et puis voilà il ya un petit esprit
festif qui peut bien correspondre à
mcadam d'une certaine manière dont
remplaçant non mais la musique a
clairement sa place à cannes et ont
notamment dans les soirées
mcadam crocodile c'est un style basé sur
des prestations en live mêlant chants et
instruments le tout au rythme de
l'électro du new disco et de l'afro funk
cette année le groupe a franchi une
étape dans son projet un album a été
enregistré en avril dans un club
parisien
au lieu de se dire on va sortir un album
de manière un peu classique on s'est dit
que ce qui correspondrait peut-être
mieux c'était d'enregistrer en fait un
live et de ce live soit l'album en fait
et donc c'est ce qu'on a fait au mois
d'avril le 11 avril on arrose trio
badaboum à paris à paris et on était
très très sur pied sous le sapin fois
qu'on vit une salle en tête d'affiche et
on ya vraiment une vieille laide la lui
répondre il y avait on avait un super
accueil voyez le monde qui est venu cet
album en live devrait sortir d'ici la
fin de l'année ou début 2011 comme
chaque soir jusqu'à demain hugo
casadamont de radio sensations depuis
cannes pour continuer de nous faire
vivre ce festival on le retrouve tout de
suite univie noises à l'honneur lors de
ce 62e festival de cannes sète isabelle
huppert qui joue dans le film frankie
d'arras axes proposés en compétition un
film grâce auquel le réalisateur prétend
gagner et remporter la palme d'or ici
alors je vous le rappelle isabelle
huppert a commencé dans les yvelines sa
carrière théâtrale à versailles alors
dans ce film isabelle huppert incarne
une célèbre actrice française qui se
serait gravement malade et qui risquent
de mourir dans quelques mois vous
proposons de l'écouter tout de suite et
de voir les premières images du film
[Musique]
from tv qui se filmer sur la maladie sur
la mort sur une personne en fin de vie
les mises mais tout le film dans son
traitement est loin de cela il n'est
jamais mélodramatique
il n'y a pas grand signe visible de
cette maladie avec 10,4 is to put n
accepte pas et fait pas tous égaux des
strips
autour des familles
[Musique]
gaultier toujours moi il m'a donné
l'opportunité de montrer la maladie le
désespoir de montrer ce qui se passe
dans l'esprit quand vous vivez ce genre
de situation de manière très réglée mais
très forte parce que la caméra est
capable de capter des petits moments des
moments fin pour les rendre très grand
c'est le pouvoir du cinéma rendre
l'infiniment petit à l'infiniment grand
c'est vraiment ça la définition du
cinéma et de la réalisation des venetian
home cinéma enfin le zoom du jour sur un
film financé par la région ile-de-france
portrait de la jeune fille en feu est en
compétition dans la sélection officielle
du festival de cannes
il est réalisé par céline sciamma
l'intrigué prend racine dans le xviiie
siècle français et 2770 marianne une
peintre doit réaliser le portrait de
mariage d'eloïse cette jeune femme qui
vient de quitter le couvent résiste à
son destin des pauses en refusant de
poser
marianne va être alors introduite comme
femmes de compagnie pour la peindre en
secret je vais aller à la messe vous
voulez communier je vais entendre de la
musique lors c'est beau mais ça l'amusé
des mois c'est la seule que je connaisse
on n'avait jamais introduire à castres
oui
racontez moi
ce n'est pas facile de raconter la
musique
[Musique]